لا يعرف هل سيثير تقسيم هذه المساعدات
جدلا كالذي تثيره المعابر الان فقبل هذا
الاعلان اعلن غوترج عن موافقه الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واكد ذلك وكيله للشؤون
الانسانيه
نرسل المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا منذ
سنوات
بدات بسبب الحاجه المتزايده جراء الزلزال
اعطاء الاسد سلطه على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واعلان سماحه باستخدام
معبرين اضافيين اغضبت دفاع المدني السوري
في شمال سوريا قال مديره رائد صالح ان ذلك
منح النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه اما وحده
تنسيق الدعم التابعه للائتلاف الوطني
السوري المعارض فقد دعت الامم المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي بتحمل مسؤولياتهم واعتبار
شمال غرب سوريا منطقه منكوبه اذا يستمر
الجدل بشان المعابر رغم حجم الكارثه التي
خلفها الزلزال فخلال الفتره الاخيره سمح
بدخول المساعدات من معبر باب الهوى دون
غيره لان الامم المتحده لم تمنح تفويدا
بذلك بسبب رفض روسيا بالخصوص التي تعتبر
استخدام هذه المعابر انتهاكا للسياده
السوريه
ورغم ان النظام اعلن من قبل انه سيسمح
بمرور المساعدات من مناطق سيطرته الى
مناطق المعارضه فان ذلك لم يحدث حتى الان
هذه قافله امميه اخرى تدخل من معبر باب
الهوى وتتالف من اثنتين وثلاثين شاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه مختلفه وهذه اول قافله
تدخل من معبر باب السلامه الى شمال سوريا
بعد موافقه النظام لا يبدو ان ايقاع دخول
هذه المساعدات يتناسب مع حجم الاحتياجات
في شمال غربي سوريا فهناك يعيش نحو اربعه
ملايين ونصف مليون سوري اصبحوا كلهم
تقريبا في حاجه الى مساعدات لكن بالنسبه
لهم المساعدات الانسانيه لا تصل حسب
حاجتهم وانما وفق حسابات سياسيه لم تهتم
يوما بحجم الكوارث